That brings us to our 2025 retro of what are we talking about? Favorite episodes, favorite moments. You said you came across your favorite. So I want to know, yeah, I want to know what episode from 2025 did best. I'm going to put it close to the camera. Read for the listener what we have here. It says, it says Ayota, hazy IPA. That can't be how they want you to pronounce it.
这让我们进入了2025年的回顾，我们在聊什么呢？最喜欢的剧集，最喜欢的时刻。你说你找到了你最喜欢的那一集。所以我很想知道，是的，我很想知道2025年哪一集表现最好。我要把它靠近镜头。给听众读一下我们这里有什么。上面写着，写着Ayota，浑浊IPA。他们肯定不是想让你这么读。
Non-alcoholic. Oh, you're going to have to send me one. You're going to have to send me one. Welcome to ADSP the podcast, episode 269, recorded on January 13th, 20206. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we conduct our 2025 annual retro. Austin, Texas. Austin, Texas. What does Austin, Texas mean?
无酒精。哦，你得给我寄一瓶。你得给我寄一瓶。欢迎收听ADSP播客，第269集，录制于2020年1月13日。我是Connor，今天和我的联合主持人Bryce一起进行我们2025年的年度回顾。德克萨斯州奥斯汀。德克萨斯州奥斯汀。德克萨斯州奥斯汀意味着什么？
Your shirt. Your shirt. Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, my bad. I'm wearing one of my many race t-shirts, and I have raced, I think twice. the no longer but formerly 3M Austin Half Marathon. I think now it's called the International Half Marathon sponsored by some other company. It's a great marathon, mostly, not Marathon, Half Marathon. Downhill mostly.
你的衬衫。你的衬衫。哦，对，对，对，我的错。我穿着我众多的比赛T恤之一，我想我参加过两次比赛。那个不再举办但曾经叫3M奥斯汀半程马拉松的比赛。我想现在它叫国际半程马拉松，由其他公司赞助。这是一场很棒的马拉松，主要是，不是马拉松，是半程马拉松。大部分是下坡路。
I love Austin. Downhill is my type of running. Ramona and I have started running recently, and it's miserable. It's just miserable. And like she, she doesn't exercise really at all right now because her arm's injured, so she hasn't been able to play tennis. And I exercise a lot, but we go out and she's just like way faster than me as way more energy and endurance. It's unfair. It takes time to get into.
我喜欢奥斯汀。下坡跑是我的强项。Ramona和我最近开始跑步了，这简直太痛苦了。简直太痛苦了。而且她，她现在基本上不怎么运动，因为她的手臂受伤了，所以她没法打网球。我经常运动，但我们一起出去时，她比我快得多，而且有更多的精力和耐力。这太不公平了。这需要时间来适应。
It takes time to get into. But she hasn't, but see, I don't buy that because she hasn't been running for years. She started again, and then she's just instantly like 10 times more athletic than me. I mean, if you used to do it, I imagine it's kind of like. like working out, if folks ever worked out in, like, university or at any point in their life, and then they stop for like a decade, you still have like the muscle memory of it. So it's way easier to get back into it if you've done it at one point in your life. I think she just has a higher tolerance for suffering than me.
这需要时间来适应。但她没有，你看，我不相信这一点，因为她已经好几年没跑步了。她重新开始，然后她立刻就比我运动能力强十倍。我的意思是，如果你以前做过，我想这有点像。就像锻炼一样，如果人们曾经在大学里或人生中任何时候锻炼过，然后他们停了十年，你仍然有肌肉记忆。所以如果你人生中曾经做过，重新开始会容易得多。我觉得她只是比我更能忍受痛苦。
But now we take the dog when we're running to it. So we go for, our route is like 4.5 kilometers. She would say it's four kilometers. but her garment watch is just not recording correctly. But the three of us go, and the dog doesn't much likely. The dog just sort of trots. The dog doesn't really run. The dog just sort of trots.
但现在我们跑步时会带上狗。所以我们去，我们的路线大约是4.5公里。她会说是4公里。但她的Garmin手表记录得不准确。但我们三个一起去，狗不太喜欢。狗只是小跑。狗并不真的跑。狗只是小跑。
And it's cold, but we've been going out most days. It's good. How is the weather in? Not that we need to bore the, maybe I'll pen X this. How is the weather in New York? Are you running metals behind you? Are they sorted by color? because I'm noticing that all the ones in the right are like,
而且天气很冷，但我们大多数日子都出去。这很好。那里的天气怎么样？不是说我们需要让听众感到无聊，也许我会把这段剪掉。纽约的天气怎么样？你身后的奖牌是在按颜色分类吗？因为我注意到右边的那些都是，
I see like dark red, then like slightly lighter red, and then some green and then blue, they are organized by color. But the ones on the right side are not like organized. You can imagine why. You can imagine why, right? You start off with it, rainbow color sorted. And then when you gain new ones,
我看到深红色，然后是稍微浅一点的红色，然后是一些绿色，然后是蓝色，它们是按颜色组织的。但右边的那些好像没有组织。你可以想象原因。你可以想象原因，对吧？你开始时，按彩虹色排序。然后当你获得新的时，
it's not like you're going to do a one rotate and shift everything. You just kind of. I mean, I would. Not every time. You got to wait until you get. like a, what do you call it, a critical mass, so it's worth it. But they, wait, wait, wait, hang on. But all of the, these are all primarily red, white, or blue.
你不可能每次都旋转并移动所有东西。你只是……我的意思是，我会的。不是每次都这样。你得等到你获得，比如，所谓的临界质量，这样才值得。但它们，等等，等等，等等，稍等。但所有这些，它们主要都是红色、白色或蓝色。
Do they not make other colors? Well, I mean, yeah, that is true. That is true. I got to spin around. There is a ton of blue. That is definitely the most common. I don't actually, I mean, a lot of the American ones, you can kind of tell by this shirt, it's got red, white, and blue.
难道它们不做其他颜色吗？嗯，我的意思是，是的，那是真的。那是真的。我得转过来。确实有很多蓝色。那绝对是最常见的。我其实不，我的意思是，很多美国的奖牌，你可以从这件衬衫上看出来，它有红色、白色和蓝色。
Marco. Yeah. And I guess the Toronto Waterfront ones are red. There's a lot of holiday. Like there's the San Diego holiday half that I've run twice. And there's the Mesa Marathon that's red. I don't know. I guess red is kind of like a celebratory, you know, jubilant.
Marco。是的。我想多伦多海滨马拉松的奖牌是红色的。有很多节日的。比如我跑过两次的圣地亚哥假日半马。还有Mesa马拉松，那是红色的。我不知道。我想红色是一种庆祝的，你知道，欢庆的颜色。
You cross the line. I don't really know. There's a... It's a... I just got back from Southeast Asia and it's like everything's red there. Oh, yeah, yeah. Well, red is like literally the... Is it lucky? The color of opulence, wealth, and luck, yes.
你冲过终点线。我真的不知道。有一个……这是一个……我刚从东南亚回来，那里什么都是红色的。哦，对，对。嗯，红色字面上就是……它是幸运的吗？财富、繁荣和好运的颜色，是的。
Yeah. But wait, here, look what I came across, Bryce. This is, I'm going to put it close to the camera. Read for the listener of what we have here. It says, it says, Iota, hazy IPA. That can't be how they want you to pronounce it. Non-alcoholic. Oh, you're going to have to send me one.
是的。但等等，看我发现了什么，Bryce。这是，我要把它靠近镜头。给听众读一下我们这里有什么。上面写着，写着Iota，浑浊IPA。他们肯定不是想让你这么读。无酒精。哦，你得给我寄一瓶。
You're going to have to send me one. It is, I couldn't believe it, folks. I've started drinking more non-alcoholic. beverages because, you know, they're better for your health. And I was in a metro, which is a Canadian grocery store. And to my surprise, right there, in between athletic brewing and a couple other brands, is the Phillips Brewing and Maltinko Iyota. Hasey IPA.
你得给我寄一瓶。它，我简直不敢相信，伙计们。我开始喝更多的无酒精饮料了，因为，你知道，它们对你的健康更好。我在Metro，那是一家加拿大杂货店。令我惊讶的是，就在那里，在Athletic Brewing和其他几个品牌之间，是Phillips Brewing and Maltinko的Iota。浑浊IPA。
I've been waiting. I have not had one of these yet, folks. It's been sitting in my little mini fridge behind me. Here we go. Just like old times, we used to crack the bubblies. now we're cracking non-alcoholic hazy IPAs. And here's the live review. That did not register.
我一直在等。伙计们，我还没喝过这个。它一直放在我身后的迷你冰箱里。我们开始吧。就像过去一样，我们过去常开气泡酒，现在我们开无酒精浑浊IPA。这是现场测评。刚才没录进去。
That did not register on my ear pods. Maybe it registers on yours. It definitely registered. I can see the little cracks in the audacity. So I hope this is amazing and it's going to be my favorite thing ever because I really would love to love the IOTA, Hasey IPA. It's everybody, honestly, I'm not even going to explain it. If you don't know what Iota is, go back in the backlog.
我的耳机没录进去。也许你的录进去了。绝对录进去了。我能看到Audacity里的小波形。所以我希望这很棒，它将成为我最喜欢的东西，因为我真的很想喜欢Iota，浑浊IPA。老实说，大家，我甚至不会解释它。如果你不知道Iota是什么，回去看之前的节目。
You got 268 episodes to listen to. Jeez, we're coming up on 300. It's pretty good. Yeah, we're getting close, man. We're getting close. We're getting there. And, oh, yeah, we got so much to talk about. So I think we're, it's good, folks.
你有268集可以听。天哪，我们快到300集了。这很不错。是的，我们快到了，伙计。我们快到了。我们快到了。而且，哦，是的，我们有很多要聊的。所以我认为我们，这很好，伙计们。
We haven't talked in, like, a while because the holiday is, like, have we recorded since your wedding? No. I mean, the last time we recorded was October 10th or 11th or something like that. That was like a long time ago. Yes. We're going to call this episode the double retro because we're going to do like a retro. of our whatever favorite episodes or highlights, ADSP, whatever.
我们已经有一段时间没聊了，因为假期，我们是在你婚礼之后录制的吗？没有。我的意思是，我们上次录制是在10月10日或11日左右。那是很久以前的事了。是的。我们要把这一集称为双重回顾，因为我们要回顾一下我们最喜欢的剧集或亮点，ADSP，等等。
But also, too, I have had a list of growing things, corrections, references to comments that we've got in the GitHub discussion. And so it's going to be one retro is addressing these things that are outstanding. And the other one is going to be like our top stuff. But yes. And also, Happy New Year. So it's been what? This is almost three months since we have recorded.
而且，我还有一份不断增加的清单，包括更正、对我们在GitHub讨论中收到的评论的引用。所以这将是一次回顾，解决这些悬而未决的事情。另一个将是我们最棒的内容。但是是的。还有，新年快乐。所以已经过了多久？距离我们上次录制已经快三个月了。
It's only been a couple days since we chatted because we chat outside. Believe it or not, we chat outside of these recordings. What should we start with? Should we start with addressing the outstanding feedback items? What do you want? I would say, yeah. All right, let's see if we can burn through these because there's like five or six of them. The reason that we have to do that is because I had a favorite episode of 2025,
距离我们聊天才过了几天，因为我们在外面聊天。信不信由你，我们在这些录音之外聊天。我们应该从什么开始？我们应该从解决悬而未决的反馈项目开始吗？你想要什么？我会说，是的。好吧，让我们看看能不能快速处理完这些，因为大约有五六个。我们必须这样做的原因是，我在2025年有一集最喜欢的剧集，
but I cannot remember what it is. So if we trust the feedback first, I'll have enough time to remember. All right. So here is my list of stuff. The first one. And I think this is in chronological order. when we were talking to what episode was this, Vittorio and J.F. in episode 259, I did not at the time go to Vittorio's talk, and I said I was going to J.F.'s talk. I did not end up going to J.F.'s talk either. I did, I think,
但我记不起是哪一集了。所以如果我们先处理反馈，我就有足够的时间回忆起来。好的。这是我的清单。第一项。我想这是按时间顺序排列的。当我们和谁谈话时，是哪一集，Vittorio和J.F.在第259集，我当时没有去Vittorio的演讲，我说我要去J.F.的演讲。我最后也没去J.F.的演讲。我想我，
watch most of it. Oh, I'm going to get text messages from J.F. about this. J.F. apparently does not know how to communicate with Conor, so anytime he needs to communicate with Connor, he sends me a text message, and then I have to text Connor. Well, the last thing that you relayed on his behalf was to add the YouTube link to the show notes of the podcast. But I had already done it. I had seen the NDC talks link in the show notes to the playlist. I don't think all of them are online because you gave a talk at NDC, correct, on top of the two trainings that we did? Yeah, I did.
看了大部分。哦，我会收到J.F.关于这件事的短信。J.F.显然不知道如何与Conor沟通，所以每当他需要与Connor沟通时，他会给我发短信，然后我必须发短信给Connor。好吧，你代表他传达的最后一件事是把YouTube链接添加到播客的节目说明中。但我已经做了。我在节目说明的播放列表中看到了NDC演讲的链接。我不认为所有演讲都在网上，因为你在NDC做了一个演讲，对吧，除了我们做的两次培训？是的，我做了。
So that is not online yet. JF's talk is, and I think most or half of the NDC Techtown talks are online. Anyways, Vittorio gave me a hard time. say why are you going to J.F.'s talk? And I didn't end up going to either. So I just, I'm not sure if Vittorio's listening. Don't feel bad. I didn't make it to either. I had to run during both of them. And Vittorio's talk isn't online either. I'm not sure if that's because he didn't want it recorded, which doesn't sound like Vittorio, it might just be in the bucket of tops that talks that are not uploaded yet. Point number two, I mentioned in one of the episodes where
所以那个还没上线。JF的演讲在网上，我想大部分或一半的NDC Techtown演讲都在网上。无论如何，Vittorio让我很难堪。说你为什么要去J.F.的演讲？我最后两个都没去。所以我只是，我不确定Vittorio是否在听。别难过。我两个都没赶上。我必须在他们演讲时跑步。而且Vittorio的演讲也不在网上。我不确定是不是因为他不想被录制，这听起来不像Vittorio，它可能只是在那些还没上传的演讲堆里。第二点，我在其中一集提到，
we were in Breda, Netherlands. I believe it was either episode 260 or 261 that the author of prefix sums and their applications was Mark Harris. That is incorrect. Mark Harris has published papers
我们在荷兰布雷达。我相信是在第260集或261集，前缀和及其应用（prefix sums and their applications）的作者是Mark Harris。这是不正确的。Mark Harris发表过关于前缀扫描的论文，
on prefix scans, but it was not that one. That is authored by Guy Bleleck. So I think I discovered that when I was trying to add it to the show notes and discovered, uh-oh, I misacredited a paper. So I will link both Guy Blalick's paper and one of Mark Harris's papers, because I think that's what I did
但不是那一篇。那是Guy Blelloch写的。所以我认为我在尝试将其添加到节目说明时发现了这一点，发现，噢，不，我错误地归功于一篇论文。所以我将同时链接Guy Blelloch的论文和Mark Harris的一篇论文，因为我想我当时也是这么做的。还有三个。所以我们要跳过这个，稍后再回来，因为它可能需要最多的讨论，或者我们可能只是把它推到另一集。也许它会是一集奖励节目。第四点，所以我们会回到第三点，我在第255集提到Pagacha来自丹麦。我说我学到了所有关于丹麦的事情。我想其中之一是嘉士伯是丹麦的官方啤酒。Pagacha不是来自丹麦，伙计们。他很有名，来自波兰。
back then as well. And there's three left. So we're going to skip this one and come back to it because it will potentially require the most discussion, or we might also just kick it to a whole other episode. Maybe it'll be a bonus episode. Number four, so we'll come back to number three, is that I mentioned in episode 255 that Pagacha was from Denmark. And I was saying I learned all this stuff about Denmark. I think one of them was that Carlsberg was the official beer of Denmark. Pagacha is not from Denmark, folks. He is famously from Poland.
那个人的名字是什么？哦，你会惹上Ramona的。是的，是的，好吧，我惹上了，我们没有这个人的名字，但他们在GitHub上的用户名是，我要把这个发音搞砸了，Vike, S.L. Gartner。他们评论说Pagacha来自波兰。哦，天哪。标签：自信地错误。
And what's the individual's name? Oh, you're going to get in trouble with Ramona. Yeah, yeah, well, I got in trouble with, we don't have this individual's name, but their username on GitHub is, I'm going to butcher this pronunciation, Vike, S.L. Gartner. And they commented pagachas from Poland. Oh, boy. Hashtaghtag confidently in Khr.
你上次去斯洛文尼亚学到了什么？无论如何，我们不仅向斯洛文尼亚国家道歉，也向丹麦国家道歉，尽管把世界上顶尖的自行车手之一，如果不是世界上顶尖的自行车手，归错国家，我想这真的不是什么坏事。第五点，在与Sean Parent的对话中，跨越了第261到263集，我想，或者可能只是262。263。我提到了abscond这个词，然后问Sean我是否正确使用了这个词，他说我用了，
correct. What did you learn on your last trip to Slovenia? Anyways, we do apologize not only to the country of Slovenia, but also to the country of Denmark, although misattributing one of the top cyclists in the world, if not the top cyclist in the world, I guess it's not really a bad thing. Number five, in the conversation with Sean Parent, which was spread across episodes 261 to 263, I think, or maybe it was just 262. 263. I mentioned the word abscond and then asked Sean if I use that word correctly and he said I did
我事后查了一下，因为我想把abscond的定义添加到节目说明中。我没有正确使用这个词。Abscond的定义是匆忙且秘密地离开，通常是为了逃避对非法行为（如盗窃）的侦查或逮捕。而我使用它的方式是，会议的几位参加者正在absconding Sean，所以我们没能立刻和他交谈。这绝对是……是的，他们偷走了Sean。什么？不，不，不，不。没关系。就像，他们带走了Sean，他们把他从他身边偷走了。不，但那，那不是。所以abscond的意思是像在不被发现的情况下离开。他们没有离开。所以无论如何，但它是离开。它是，它是离开而不被发现。就像，你可以说abscond with an item。就像，他，
and I looked it up afterward because I was wanting to add the definition of abscond to the show notes. I did not use the word correctly. The definition of abscond is to leave hurriedly and secretly typically to avoid detection of or arrest for an unlawful action such as theft. And the way that I used it was a couple of attendees of the conference were absconding Sean so we weren't able to talk to him right away. And that is definitely... Yeah, they stole Sean. What? No, no, no, no. That's fine. Like, they took Sean and they stole him away from him. No, but that's, that's not. So to abscond is means to like to exit without detection. They did not exit. So anyways, but it's to exit. It's, it's to exit without detection. Like, you could say to abscond with an item. Like, he,
带着黄金潜逃了之类的。我想也许吧。我的意思是，也许有一些，我们有几千名听众。如果外面有文字大师，我们没有收到任何评论，但当我得到定义时，它似乎不正确。所以我问了几个LLM，是否有我试图寻找但没找到的词。但它并没有真正给我，他们建议的首选是accost，这绝对是不正确的，因为那是当你有点像咄咄逼人地，你知道，走到某人面前，
absconded with the gold or something. I guess maybe. I mean, maybe there's some, we've got like several thousand listeners. If someone's a wordsmith out there, we didn't get any comments, but it seemed incorrect when I got the definition. And so I asked a couple LLMs if there was a word that I was trying to reach for but couldn't. But it didn't really give me the top one they suggested was a cost, which is definitely incorrect, because that's when you kind of like aggressively, you know, go up to someone.
和他们交谈之类的，这并不不正确，但绝对不是accosted。然后还有其他几个选项是detained，waylaid。无论如何，也许abscond是正确的。去GitHub讨论区。如果你是文字大师，请告诉我们。如果你知道我试图寻找的词，无论如何，关于abscond就说这么多。然后第三点，所以这是我写下的五件事中最后但并非最不重要的一点。我们收到了多条评论。
talk to them or whatever, which isn't incorrect, but it's definitely not accosted. And then that couple other options were detained, waylaid. Anyways, maybe abscond was correct. Go to the get up discussion. If you are a wordsmith, let us know. And if you know the word that I was reaching for, anyways, enough on abscond. And then number three, so this is last but not least of the five things I had written down. We got multiple comments.
我想我在我们旅行或什么的某个时候向你提到过这一点。我们谈到了特斯拉的情况，以及我在奥胡斯到哥本哈根的Polestar公路旅行时没有特斯拉的事实。在那一集里，我说，将艺术与艺术家分开。我后悔买了普锐斯。我希望我买了特斯拉。伙计们，有一个小插曲。
And I think I had mentioned this to you at some point while we were traveling or or whatever. We talked about the Tesla situation and the fact that I don't have a Tesla when we were road tripping from Orhus to Copenhagen in the Polestar. And at one point in that episode, I said, separate the art from the artist. I regret having gotten a Prius. I wish I got a Tesla. And folks, there's a little sidebar.
我更后悔了。特斯拉，冬天开普锐斯？天哪。别让我开始。别让我开始，伙计们。无论如何，我们有多个人评论。我们将完整地阅读，也许我们不会，我们只是，我们会提到他们的名字Robert。如果你真的想，你可以去找到他们的用户名，因为它公开贴在GitHub账户旁边。
I regret it even more. Tesla, a Prius in the winter? My goodness. Don't get me started. Don't get me started, folks. And anyways, we had multiple individuals comment. And we'll read in the entirety from, maybe we won't, we'll just, we'll name them Robert. You can go find their username if you really want to because it's publicly posted next to a GitHub account.
这是回复。还有第二个也问了几个不同的问题，但我们只读这一个。引用，对不起，我试过了。当他的一些艺术作品是关于支持我居住地极右翼的崛起时，我无法将艺术与艺术家分开。我没有那种特权。我想我再检查一下，因为这篇文章提到了电动汽车，我甚至不在乎你们中任何人拥有特斯拉，
This is the response. And there was a second one as well that asked a couple different things, but we'll just read this one. Quote, I'm sorry, I tried. I can't separate the art from the artist when some of his art is about supporting the rise of the far right where I live. I don't have that privilege. I thought I'd check again, seeing as this post-mentioned EVs, I wouldn't even care about any of you owning a Tesla,
但我无法支持提议和/或合理化给埃隆更多的钱去攻击其他人的自由、权利和福祉。多年来我从你们的播客中获得了大量有用的信息，我仍然非常感谢这一点，但对我来说，这是终点。我遗憾地不会再收听了，但仍然祝你们一切顺利，引用结束。
but I can't support proposing and or rationalizing, giving Elon even more money to attack the freedom, liberties, and well-being of other people. I've gotten lots of great information from your podcast throughout the years, and I'm still very thankful for that, but for me, it's the end of the road here. I sadly won't be checking in again, but still wish you guys all the best, end quote.
除了我的一些口误。我的意思是，我们不想让这一整集都关于特斯拉，但你有即时的回应吗，Bryce？我们对失去一位听众感觉如何？看到有人离开我很遗憾。也许我们应该，也许这是一个我们应该避开的领域。问题是，因为我不想，我不想让人们在听播客时感到难过。我不想提起那些对人们来说有很多包袱的事情。所以我很抱歉。也许我们不应该去那里。是的，我的意思是，我认为总的来说，我们有，我的意思是，有时我们提到了政治相关的东西，
modulo a couple of my speakos. And I mean, we don't want to make this whole episode about Tesla, but do you have an instant response, Bryce? How do we feel about having lost a listener? I'm sorry to see somebody go. And maybe we should, maybe this is a lane we should stay out. The thing is, because I don't want, I don't want people to feel bad when listening to the podcast. and I don't want to bring up stuff that's got lots of baggage for folks. So I'm sorry. Perhaps we should not have gone there. Yeah, I mean, I think in general, we have, I mean, at times we've brought up political stuff
或者与政治相关的东西，而且从来没有好结果。所以我认为随着时间的推移，我们只是试图要么保持在技术话题上，要么保持在非技术性的有趣话题上，或者只是人们关心或不关心的废话。我的意思是，在我们其中一集丹麦节目中的评论之一是，你知道，我听了15分钟，他们还没提到任何关于算法的东西。我退出了。所以我当时想，好吧。但人们现在应该知道了。带有信息点缀的混乱。
slash adjacent to a political stuff, and it never goes well. So I think over time, we have just tried to either stay on technical topics or non-technical fun topics or just nonsense that people care or do not care about. I mean, one of the comments on one of our Denmark episodes was, you know, I'm 15 minutes in, and they haven't mentioned anything about algorithms. I'm out. So I was like, okay. But people should know by now. Chaos with sprinkles of information.
有时混乱更多，有时信息更多。我的意思是，但我们也，我们有，那次公路旅行产生了我现在发现的年度最爱剧集。那次公路旅行产生了一些非常棒的内容，我想。我的意思是，我不知道，你有2025年哪些剧集表现最好的数据吗？我可以调出来。我可能需要稍微目测一下，或者我可以快速把它喂给LLM。但我的意思是，每当我看到那些评论说，哦，他们什么都没谈，我完全不同意，因为很多时候我们谈论的是虚无，
Sometimes more chaos, sometimes more information. And I mean, but we also, we had some, that road trip produced what I have now found my favorite episode of the year. That, that road trip produced some really gold content, I think. I mean, I don't know, do you have the numbers of what episodes from 2025 did best? I can bring them up. I might need to eyeball it a bit or I could quickly feed it to an LLM. But I mean, whenever I see those comments of like, oh, they're not talking about anything, I completely disagree because a lot of times we're talking about nothing,
但随后我们立刻深入到，你知道，关于CPU或GPU上算法的一些讨论。所以无论如何，你知道，如果你不喜欢这些废话，那没关系。也许这个播客不适合你。但是，你知道，这是我们品牌的一部分，你知道，有时我们在谈论随机话题。话虽如此，特斯拉/普锐斯的东西，它并不，它不是故意的。我想当我们谈论我能不能买它时，它是一件政治性的事情。但是，你知道，它也是，它也是一个技术产品，如果你愿意的话。
but then we instantly drop down into, you know, some discussion about algorithms on the CPU or GPU. So anyways, you know, if you don't like the fluff, that's fine. maybe this podcasting for you. But, you know, it's part of our brand at this point that, you know, sometimes we're talking about random talk. It's that being said, the Tesla slash Priya stuff, it doesn't, it's not intend. I guess when we're talking about can I buy it, it is a political thing. But, you know, it is, it's also like a technology product, if you will.
我想这就是为什么我们转向了它。我确实对平台化感到难过，你知道，谈论它，然后可能鼓励人们。话虽如此，你知道，我只是，你知道，我一直听到这些Nvidia，Mercedes，Alpameo，什么的，全自动驾驶。我能买到全自动驾驶的梅赛德斯吗？我一直在Jensen的主题演讲中听到调制解调器。但我们能买到自动驾驶的梅赛德斯吗？
And I guess that's why we veered into it. I do feel bad about platforming, you know, talking about it and then potentially encouraging folks. That being said, you know, I just, you know, I keep on hearing about these Nvidia, Mercedes, Alpameo, whatever, full self-driving. Can I buy a full self-driving Mercedes? I keep hearing a modem in the keynotes that Jensen gives. But can we buy a self-driving Mercedes?
无论如何，还有其他选择吗，你知道？我很乐意支持另一家公司。但是的，也许未来，我们不会触及那些东西。我不知道。也许是那些对我们有评论感到不安的人，也许其他人喜欢这个讨论。人们不在乎吗？我们需要你们的反馈，伙计们，在GitHub讨论区。让我们知道你们是否想避开这些东西，因为，你知道，我确实对谈论这些内容感到难过。如果它是，你知道，重点是玩得开心，
Anyways, are there other options, you know? I'm happy to support a different company. But yeah, maybe going forward, we won't touch that stuff. I don't know. Maybe it's the people that are upset that we've. comments, maybe other people enjoy the discussion. Do people not care? We need your feedback, folks, on the GitHub discussion. Let us know if you want to veer away from this stuff, because, you know, I do feel bad talking about this content. If it's like, you know, the point is to have
谈论算法。如果我们因为他们不想听到这些东西而劝阻人们收听，而他们正在受苦。这让我想起，还有另一个跑步播客，我停止收听了，因为我喜欢技术内容。但每当他们谈论个人事情时，它就让我抓狂。我知道我的跑步俱乐部里有几个人也是一样。技术内容很棒，但他们一点也不在乎他们谈论的所有其他事情。我想知道我们有多少比例的听众是那样的，每当我们开始谈论教练时，人们就会感到恼火。无论如何，如果你有反馈。有一个，有一个建议。我正在和LLM交谈。它确实建议有一个试点项目，
fun and talk about algorithms. And if we're discouraging people from listening because they don't want to hear about this stuff and they're suffering through. And that reminds me, there was another running podcast that I stopped listening to because I loved the technical stuff. But whenever they would talk about personal stuff, it drove me up the mall. And I knew like a few people in my run club that it was the same thing. The technical content was amazing, but they could care less for all the other stuff they talked about. I wonder what percentage of our listeners are like that, where whenever we start talking about coaches, people get irritated. Anyways, if you have feedback. There is, there is a suggestion. I'm talking to the LM. It does suggest that there is a pilot program
针对美国的梅赛德斯自动驾驶，但仅限于加利福尼亚州和内华达州，并且仅在特定条件下，比如当有，比如，如果你在交通堵塞中，并且速度低于40英里每小时。但是……是的，他们不会为我削减它。另外两个列出的是，是，
for Mercedes self-drive in the U.S., but only in California and Nevada, and only in certain conditions, like when there's, like, if you're in a traffic jam and it's less than, you're going less than 40 miles an hour. But... Yeah, they ain't going to cut it for me. The other two listed is, is, uh,
通用汽车的自动驾驶产品和福特的自动驾驶产品。但我怀疑那些也不会做到。但让我们问问加拿大。让我们问问加拿大。我的意思是，我不认为会有什么不同。我们对替代方案做了一些研究。我想我们提到了比亚迪。我们甚至研究过从墨西哥进口它，因为它就像顶级的电动汽车之一，
GM's self-driving product and Ford's self-driving product. But I suspect that those are also not going to do it. But let's ask about Canada. Let's ask about Canada. I mean, I don't think it's going to be different. We did some research into alternatives. I think we mentioned B.D. And we even looked into importing it from Mexico because it's like one of the top electric vehicles
和自动驾驶选项。但从不在制裁名单上的不同国家进口汽车是非法的。它本来会更便宜。而且，即使你能进口这辆车，除非得到当地当局的批准，否则你可能无法使用自动驾驶功能。哦，对，对，可能。无论如何，伙计们，我们不是想谈论这个更多。我未来会换车吗？也许未来没人会知道，因为我们把我们的收视率放在了线上。
and self-driving options. But it is illegal to import a car from a different country that's not on the sanction list. It would have still been cheaper. Also, even if you could import the car, you probably couldn't use self-driving feature unless it's approved by the local authorities. Oh, yeah, yeah, potentially. Anyways, folks, we don't mean to talk about this more. Will I switch cars in the future? Maybe nobody will know in the future because we're putting our viewership on the line.
我们不想那样做。无论如何，那些是，那是我们回顾的第一部分，回顾过去。感谢所有留下评论的人，我们为所犯的错误道歉。这让我们进入了2025年的回顾，我们在聊什么呢？最喜欢的剧集？最喜欢的时刻？你说你找到了你最喜欢的那一集。所以我很想知道，是的，我很想知道2025年哪一集表现最好。
And we don't want to do that. Anyways, those are, that's the first part of our retcho was going back. Thanks to everybody left comments and we apologize for the mistakes that were made. That brings us to our 2025 retro of what are we talking about? Favorite episodes? Favorite moments? You said you came across your favorite. So I want to know, yeah, I want to know what episode from 2025 did best.
我的意思是，我确实，他们确实给我发了一封电子邮件，这个小，如果你提出来叫什么？你知道Spotify是怎么做年度总结的，然后每个人都开始抄袭他们？Buzzsprout，我用于播客的平台，给我发了同样的东西。如果我尝试去找到它，那是三兄弟。是的，在这里。我记得观看次数最多的第一集仍然是第零集，压倒性地。在这一点上，剧集的数据是，我想我们有84,000次收听，
I mean, I did, they did actually send me in an email, this little, what do you call it if I bring it up? You know how Spotify does the unwrapped and then everyone has started copying them? Buzz Sprout, which is the platform that I use for the podcast, sent me the same kind of thing. And if I try and go find it, it was three bros. Yeah, here it is. And I remember that the number one most viewed episode was still episode zero, overwhelmingly. And at this point, the stats on the episodes are like, I think we have 84,000 listens.
在第零集上，总计，这几乎占了10%。就像我们总共有110万或120万次下载。这对未来的播客主是一个教训。确保第零集是一个重磅炸弹，你的音频是在点的。因为我敢肯定，如果我们有更高质量的音频，我们的收视率会高出几个百分点。如果我去检查这里的播放，我可以分享我的屏幕一秒钟。当你在做，当你在做这些手动工作时，我只是在问一个LLM，ADSP播客在2025年哪一集有最多的观看/收听/下载。
on episode zero, like in aggregate, which accounts for almost like 10%. Like we have like 1.1 or 1.2 million downloads in total. And that is a lesson for future podcasters. Make sure episode zero is a banger and your audio is on point. Because I'm sure our viewership would be like some single digit percentage higher if we had higher quality audio. And if I go to check this playback here, I can share my screen for a second. I'm just asking an LLM while you're doing, while you're doing this manual work, I'm just asking an LOM, what episode of ADSP the Bodd Task in 2025 had the most views slash listen slash downloads.
我们发布了25集，不出所料，播客位置。所以你在看这个，对吧？也许我会发布这个。我觉得它有点傻，所以我没发。我正在尝试看它，但我的带宽似乎非常糟糕。所以现在它只是向我显示一个大的C.E.给Connor。但我想如果我们再等五秒钟左右。好吧，问题是它就像，
We published 25 episodes, unsurprising, podcast location. So you're looking at this, right? Maybe I'll post this. I thought it was kind of silly, so I didn't. I am attempting to look at it, but my bandwidth seems to be very bad. So right now it is just showing me a big C.E. for Connor. But I imagine if we wait another five seconds or so. Well, the thing is it's like
一个动画视频。所以它说美国是我们收听率最受欢迎的国家。我们在23,429个不同的城市被收听。最城市，最受欢迎的城市是纽约。而且，
an animated video. So it's saying the United States was our most popular country for listenership. And we were listened to in 23,429 different cities. The most city, most popular city was New York. And
嘿，我的人民。和顶级国家。所以那是美国、德国和英国。顶级城市是纽约。纽约、悉尼和斯德哥尔摩。虽然动画已经过去了。我们在2025年获得了超过四分之一百万的下载量。有一集真的脱颖而出。
Hey, my people. And top countries. So that is United States, Germany, and United Kingdom. Top Cities is New York. New York, Sydney, and Stockholm. Although the animation has gone by. We got over a quarter million downloads in 2025. One episode really stood out.
那就是第零集，我们最喜欢的算法，有8,460次下载。甚至不是今年出来的。或者去年。或者去年。我们处于播客的前5%。哇！它会向我们展示我们其他最受欢迎的剧集，我相信，那是第247集，优秀软件设计的哲学，然后是第244集，沉迷于AI，第一部分。第一部分。
And that was episode zero, our favorite algorithms with 8,460 downloads. Didn't even come out this year. Or the last year. Or the last year. And we're in the top 5% of podcasts. Whoa! And it's going to show us our other top episodes, I believe, which were episode 247, the philosophy of good software design, and then episode 244, high on AI, part one. The first one.
247，2025年开始于，好吧，所以那是2025年的一集。是的，那两集都在夏天。时间。一集有3,900次观看，另一集有3,700次观看。我不惊讶沉迷于AI那一集排在前面。然后有一个ADSP的总结，显示了五年的播客，发布了52集，前5%，四分之一百万下载，我想这都是同样的统计数据。然后我们发布的总分钟数是1,711，除以52可能是，什么，32，33分钟左右？所以我打算给人们一个通行证，因为我今年最喜欢的一集是在，
247, 2025 started with, okay, so that was a 2025 episode. Yeah, both of those were in the summertime. time. One had 3,900 views and the other one had 3,700 views. I'm not surprised the high on AI one is up there. And then there's a summary of ADSP, which shows five years of podcasting, 52 episodes published, top 5%, quarter million down, I guess it's just all the same stats. And then the total number of minutes we published were 1,711, which divided by 52 is probably going to be, what, 32, 33 minutes or something like that? So I'm going to give people a pass because my favorite episode of the year was posted in
12月发布的，你知道，12月在科技界什么都没发生。好吧，我猜除了Nvidia，签署协议。但除此之外，除此之外。Jensen在圣诞节非常忙。除此之外，12月什么都没发生。所以我们几周后再来看看我最喜欢的那一集是否真的火了起来。但你知道我在想哪一集吗？如果是在12月，我猜是Sean Parent的起源故事，对吧？
December and, you know, nothing happens in Tekken in December. Well, I guess aside from Nvidia, signing deals. But other than that, other than that. Jensen's very busy on Christmas. Other than that, nothing happens in December. So we'll check back in a few weeks and see whether my favorite one is really picked up steam. But do you know which episode I'm thinking of? If it was in December, I'm going to guess it was the Sean Parent origin story, correct?
是的，当然。必须是。我很难过我不得不离开酒店，因为我是要飞走吗？我想我得去赶我的航班。你的航班是第二天早上，但那是第二天早上很早，你得赶上最后一班去阿姆斯特丹的火车，我相信。是的，我想我那天晚上得离开。我得去赶火车。就像，如果只是我不得不，如果只是我不会有任何睡眠的问题，我会留下来。但就像，我需要赶上一班火车，这是最后一班。所以我不得不离开，因为我住的酒店实际上是在机场安检之后，那是一次有趣的经历。但是的，我很遗憾我不得不离开。我离开后你们又聊了多久？我，好吧，所以我甚至认为人们在剪辑中没注意到，因为我剪掉了你离开的时候。然后我想我们又录制了也许，我不记得是10分钟还是20分钟。
Yes, of course. It has to be. And I was so sad that I had to leave the hotel because was I flying out? I think I had to go catch my flight. Your flight was the next morning, but it was early in the next morning, and you had to catch the last train to Amsterdam, I believe. Yes, I think I had to leave that night. I had to get on a train. Like, if it was just like I had to, if it was just a question of I would not get any sleep, I would have stayed. But it was like, I needed to be on a train and this was the last train. And so I had to depart because I stayed at a hotel that was actually like inside the airport past security, which was an interesting experience. But yes, I was sad that I had to leave. How much longer did you guys talk after I left? I, well, so I don't even think people noticed in the edit because I cut out when you were leaving. And then I think we recorded for another maybe, I can't remember if it was 10 or 20 minutes.
所以我认为每个人都以为你一直在那里。是的，我只认为那是10到20分钟。我们完成了那个。然后我们最后加入了一群在某家餐厅的人。我们的桌子上有太多人了，但那很有趣。然后，所以我们又玩了几个小时，但我们只录制了10或20分钟。有趣的是，所以这是统计数据。如果你对剧集进行反向最大扫描，你可以看到那些，每周有更多的人。
And so I think everybody thought you were there for the whole time. Yeah, and I only think it was 10 to 20 minutes. We finished that. And then we ended up joining a bunch of folks that were at some restaurant. And we had way too many people at a table, but it was a lot of fun. And then, so we hung out for a few more hours, but we only recorded for 10 or 20 more minutes. And what's interesting is that, so here are the stats. And if you do a reverse max scan on the episodes, you can kind of see the ones that on, like, per week have more.
所以实际上，那两集Sean Parent确实比前两周多。但那只是那两周，然后是与J.F. Bastion和Vittorio的NDC Tech Town，那一集多了45次观看。然后算法分类做得很好。所以这就是那些脱颖而出的，对吧？但然后算法分类，
So actually, those two Sean Parent episodes do have more than the previous two weeks. but that is only for those two weeks and then the NDC Tech Town with J.F. Bastion and Vittorio that one has 45 views more. And then algorithm taxonomy did pretty well. So then that's the ones that kind of stand out, right? But then the algorithm taxonomy
跳到了3,200或3,200。然后如果我们继续向后滚动，所以我们下一次有更高的是什么时候？那是我们之前最后一次邀请Sean Parent的时候。所以这可能确实表明Sean Parent的那些会随着时间的推移产生更多的观看次数。然后，是的，这个4001软件设计哲学。
that skips up to 3.200 or 3,200. And then if we keep scrolling back, so when's the next time we have one that's higher? It was the last time we had Sean Parent on before that. So that probably does indicate that the Sean Parent ones will generate more views over time. And then, yeah, this 4001 philosophy of software design.
等等，等等。那些Sean Parent的录音，那是九月？那是我们在Zoom通话上做的时候。所以那是八月下旬我们录制的时候。我们，我想，录制了，我不知道，几个小时。然后，是的，我们把它切碎了。这个播客真的是与Sean Parent的讨论。真的有很多Sean。
Wait, wait, wait. Which recording of those Sean Parent ones, those were September? That was when we did it on the Zoom call. So that was late August when we recorded. And we, I think, recorded for, I don't know, a couple hours. And then, yeah, we diced it up. This podcast really is a discussion with Sean Parent. There's really a lot of Sean.
有几个不同的。它是ADSP。与Sean的讨论。unparent，算法加数据结构等于程序。还有另一个。你还记得是什么吗？我不记得了。无论如何，所以我说我最喜欢的。
There was a couple different. It's ADSP. A discussion with Sean. unparent, algorithms plus data structures equals programs. There was another one. Do you remember what it was? I can't remember. Anyway, so I will say my favorite.
好吧，是的，我想我没有花大量时间去思考它，但它是三月份的那一集。而且我实际上很难过，因为我们没有，我没有更新它，因为我很确定我添加了一个，我添加了吗？哦，不，我没有。我想我只有在参加会议时才会添加表情符号旗帜。这看起来像模式，因为我们录制了。现场来自不同的国家，
Well, yeah, I think I didn't spend a ton of time thinking about it, but it was the one in March. And I'm actually sad because we didn't, I didn't update it, because I'm pretty sure I added a, did I add? Oh, no, I didn't. I guess I only add emoji flags when we're at conferences. That looks like the pattern, because we have recorded. live from different countries,
但是，而且我猜你是在美国，所以这可能就是我没做它的原因。但我们录制了，如果你还记得，在那场喜剧表演之后，我们回到了酒店。我记得。而且我玩得很开心。每当我们走路和交谈时。
but, and I guess you're based in the state, so that's probably why I didn't do it. But we recorded, if you recall, after that comedy show, and we went back to the hotel. I do. And I just had a ton of fun. Whenever we're walking and talking.
是的，那是一集很好的。那是一集很好的。而且，事后看来，我们评论了，或者你评论了那位犹太喜剧演员是你最喜欢的。有，他很有名。Ari Shafir？哦，真的吗？
Yeah, that was a good one. That was a good one. And also, too, in hindsight, we commented on, or you commented on the Jewish comedian was your favorite. There is, he's famous. Ari Shafir? Oh, really?
是的，他是一位著名的喜剧演员。就像，他上过Joe Rogan。他在，就像，Joe Rogan的圈子里。而且……什么，我们不去那里，Donna。无论如何，所以，是的，不，我猜我们的听众，也许我们在那里失去了一些听众，因为你喜欢一个上过Joe Rogan播客的喜剧演员。无论如何，事后我意识到，就像，哦，是的，我以前见过那个人。
Yeah, he's a famous comedian. Like, he's been on Joe Rogan. He's in, like, the Joe Rogan sphere. And... What, we're not going there, Donna. Anyways, so, yeah, no, I guess our listeners, maybe we lost a couple listeners there because you liked a comedian that's been on the Joe Rogan podcast. Anyways, after the fact, I realized that, like, oh, yeah, I've seen that guy before.
而且我最，我最著名地知道他。从Shane Gillis嘲笑他。无论如何，我们到了30分钟大关。还有其他我们想回顾的事情吗……好吧，所以我在12月问过你这个问题，也许听众可以提供一些意见。我很想做一个民意调查，找出你们，听众，你们2025年最喜欢的剧集是什么。
And I'm in most, I most famously know him. from Shane Gillis roasting him. Anyways, we're at the 30-minute mark. Are there other things we want to retro about... Well, okay, so I had asked you about this in December, and maybe the listeners can provide some input. I would love to do some sort of poll to find out what you, the listener, what your favorite episode was from 2025.
我心里想的是，就像我有时在Twitter上看到的那样，人们进行多轮民意调查，就像疯狂三月。就像，你知道，你做一个括号。你做，你烘焙出一堆不同的，你知道，你拿四个，你说这四个中哪个是最好的，然后你进入下一轮，你做一堆那些民意调查，你做，你知道，四组，然后你进入下一轮，等等，等等，等等，直到最终你进入一个最终的单一民意调查，决定赢家。
And I kind of had in mind, like I sometimes see on Twitter where people do like multiple rounds of polls like March Madness. Like, you know, you make a bracket. You do, you bake off a bunch of different, you know, you take four and you say which of these four is the best and then you go to the next round and you do a bunch of those polls where you do, you know, sets of four and then you move on to the next round and etc., etc., etc., until eventually you advance to a final single poll that determines the winner.
但这就像很多民意调查。而且我不认为我不认为我能让每个人的注意力保持那么久。那么最好的选择是什么？我们只是去挑选下载量最高的12集，或者我们最喜欢的12集，把它们放进民意调查里？或者什么机制最好？一年肯定有52集。所以我们让人们投票选出他们52集最喜欢的剧集的最佳机制是什么？在他们最喜欢的剧集中。
But that's like a lot of polls. and I don't think I don't think I'll be able to retain everyone's attention for that long. So then what is the best option? Do we just go and pick like the 12 episodes that had the highest downloads or 12 episodes that like we like the best and put them into a poll? Or like what's the best mechanism? There must be 52 episodes from the air. So what's the best mechanism for us to let people vote on their 52 favorite episodes? on their favorite episode of those 52.
而且，我的意思是，我们之前已经征求过关于特斯拉话题的反馈了。但如果你有一般的反馈，我们已经这样做五年多了。如果有什么，我的意思是，我们从不同的人那里听到了不同的事情，你知道。有些人喜欢10倍速的家伙。有些人不喜欢10倍速。Zach Lane。他说那是他最喜欢节目的地方。每当我把你的声音调到10倍速的时候。
And also, too, I mean, we already solicited feedback earlier about the Tesla topic. But if you have feedback in general, we've been doing this for over five years now. And if there is, I mean, we've heard different things from different people, you know. Some people like the 10xing, guys. Some people don't like 10xing. Zach Lane. He said that's his like favorite thing about the show. It was whenever I 10X your voice.
另外，我的意思是，我们之前已经征求过关于特斯拉话题的反馈了。但如果你有任何一般的反馈，我们做这个节目已经超过五年了。而且，我的意思是，我们从不同的人那里听到了不同的声音。有些人喜欢“10倍速”，有些人不喜欢。扎克·莱恩（Zach Lane）说这是他最喜欢的节目环节，就是我把你的声音调成10倍速的时候。
I've heard other people, they said, Their favorite story was the back and forth during COVID about you sending me, like me getting COVID, not being able to get a vaccine, or what was it a test? And then you like sending me the test. And then other people, they say that their favorite stuff is the algorithm talk. Anyways, if you let us know not just like what your favorite episode is or how you want us to do that kind of vote, but like what's your favorite part or is it all of the above? Anyways, we're open to feedback.
我听别人说，他们最喜欢的故事是新冠期间我们之间的互动，比如你给我寄东西，或者我得了新冠没法打疫苗，又或者是别的什么测试？然后你给我寄测试盒。还有人说他们最喜欢的是关于算法的讨论。总之，如果你能告诉我们，不仅是你最喜欢哪一集，或者你希望我们怎么进行投票，还有你最喜欢的部分是什么，或者以上皆是？总之，我们欢迎大家的反馈。
You know, we want to keep our listeners happy. And, yeah, maybe we'll do, maybe Bryce will do something if we get a good enough suggestion on some kind of poll or something like that. And I guess we could, we could, I know how we could encourage, we could encourage participation is we could give out some prize, right? If you, if you participate in the poll. I don't know what sort of prize we could give out. Do you have a prize to give out, an Nvidia ruler or something like that? I could make ADSP t-shirts or something. That was a quick upgrade.
你知道，我们想让听众满意。而且，是的，也许我们会做点什么，如果能收到关于投票之类的好的建议，也许 Bryce 会做点什么。我想我们可以鼓励大家参与，比如我们可以提供一些奖品，对吧？如果你参与了投票。我不知道能提供什么样的奖品。你有什么奖品可以送吗，比如 Nvidia 的尺子之类的？我可以制作 ADSP 的 T 恤什么的。那升级得挺快。
We finally got stickers, and then a couple months later we got T-shirts. Well, I had to have T-shirts made for another purpose that I cannot disclose on the podcast. But it was pretty straightforward. All right. Well, there you go, folks. Maybe the potential to have a T-shirt. There's no promises here because. I'd be very surprised if these t-shirts materialized, but if they do, you might be the proud owner.
我们终于有了贴纸，几个月后又有了 T 恤。好吧，我不得不为了另一个不能在播客上透露的目的制作 T 恤。但这很简单。好了，各位，就是这样。也许有机会能拿到 T 恤。这里不做任何承诺，因为如果这些 T 恤真的做出来了，我会非常惊讶，但如果真的有，你可能会成为自豪的拥有者。
And how do they win it? Is this anybody? Like, no, like, you know, we'll randomly choose five people who, uh, who comment on some platform. Participate in the poll. Yeah, no, no, no, no, who vote on the poll of the, what was their favorite episode of 2025. Okay. Well, have we decided we're doing a poll yet? Uh, if I can find a way to construct the poll, then yeah.
那他们怎么赢呢？是任何人都可以吗？不，你知道，我们会从在某个平台上评论的人中随机抽取五个人。参与投票。对，不，不，不，是那些在 2025 年最喜欢的一集投票中投票的人。好吧。那我们决定要进行投票了吗？呃，如果我能找到一种构建投票的方法，那就行。
I want to research. There's got to be some clever way of doing this. Okay. Like giving people just 52 options, it cannot be the best way. Like I don't, doing the bracket is like, you know, a good way, but then that requires you to do multiple rounds, right? So people have to be engaged multiple times. I guess, like, asking people to, like, just pick from a list of 52, I feel like that's, that can't be the best way. There has to be theory on this and what's the best.
我想研究一下。一定有某种巧妙的方法来做这件事。给人们 52 个选项肯定不是最好的方法。做对阵表是个好方法，但这需要多轮投票，对吧？所以人们必须多次参与。我想，让人们从 52 个选项的列表中选择，我觉得这不可能是最好的方法。关于什么是最好的投票方式一定有相关的理论。
way to to poll. Well, I mean, technically on this episode, we could just say if you have a favorite episode, go leave a comment within the GitHub discussion. Or maybe I could even create like a separate GitHub discussion for a favorite episode. Go leave the number. And then if people see it in the future, they just upvote it. And then as you're missing such a wonderful opportunity to talk about like ballot design and like algorithms for determining consensus.
好吧，我的意思是，从技术上讲，在这一集中，我们可以直接说如果你有最喜欢的一集，去 GitHub 讨论区留言。或者我甚至可以为最喜欢的一集创建一个单独的 GitHub 讨论。留下编号。如果以后有人看到，他们只需点赞。你错失了一个谈论投票设计和确定共识算法的绝佳机会。
You're making it too complicated. You're making it too complicated. Jeffrey, and I'll say this, Jeffrey Askin, who was the Library ofolution Chair when I started on the C++ committee, best library evolution share, I think we've ever had. He did like all this research on polling methods and like, you know, techniques for determining consensus and he had all this theory crafting on it. He would know, he would know what the right mechanism is. He came up with this like, these strategies for how we would prioritize stuff.
你把它搞得太复杂了。你把它搞得太复杂了。Jeffrey，我要说的是，Jeffrey Askin，当我刚加入 C++ 委员会时，他是图书馆演进主席，我认为他是我们有史以来最好的图书馆演进主席。他做了所有关于投票方法的研究，以及确定共识的技术，他对此有所有的理论构思。他会知道什么是正确的机制。他想出了这些策略，关于我们如何优先处理事情。
Like you're given a list of like a hundred things. How do you ask a group of people to prioritize those hundred things? And one of the things we used to do was we would, you would take an item and you'd ask everybody to raise their hands and you would start at the top of the list and you would ask people to put their hands down as you moved the item further and further down the list you'd ask them to lower their hands when the item reached the place in the list that they thought it belonged and then when roughly half the people in the room had lowered their hands that's where the item would live and it was like a pretty fast way to go through and prioritize a bunch of items because like you just you just go through and then just like once you know some enough hands had gone
比如给你一个包含一百件事的列表。你如何要求一群人优先处理这 100 件事？我们过去常做的一件事是，你会拿出一个项目，让每个人举手，然后从列表顶部开始，当你把项目在列表中向下移动时，你会要求人们放下手，当项目到达他们认为应该在的位置时，让他们放下手，然后当房间里大约一半的人放下手时，那就是该项目应该在的位置，这是一种快速遍历并优先处理一堆项目的方法，因为你只需要遍历，一旦你知道有足够多的人举手
down to be like all right and you didn't have to like ask people to uh like say like oh i think it should be 24th or 25th or something there was no like discussion about it it was just like each person individually would put their hand down and i think it was a really a really good strategy All right, well, we're not doing that because we don't have people sitting in a room. What if you... I think we're putting way too much thought into it because in honesty, I can't even recall half of the episodes that we've recorded by like number or title or what we talked about. I have already in my head just like a handful that were the favorites and most memorable for me.
放下手，就像这样，你不需要要求人们说，哦，我认为它应该是第 24 或 25 位之类的，没有关于它的讨论，只是每个人单独放下手，我认为这是一个非常好的策略。好吧，我们不这样做，因为我们没有人在房间里坐着。如果你……我觉得我们想得太多了，因为老实说，我甚至记不起我们录制的一半剧集的编号、标题或我们谈论的内容。我脑子里已经有几个我最喜欢和最难忘的了。
And I think it would be generous. Like, what are the people recording it and producing it? I think it would be very unlikely that our listeners have more of a memory for our episodes than we do. So they probably only have one or two. So you just go ask them to leave a comment and then they upvote it and then we're done. And if we get some overwhelming, you know, 20 different episodes and people disagreeing, then we just look at the upvotes and then we have a final poll or something and that's it. But, you know, it's way too complicated.
而且我认为这会很慷慨。录制和制作它的人呢？我认为我们的听众对我们剧集的记忆力比我们好是不太可能的。所以他们可能只有一两个。所以你只需要让他们留下评论，然后他们点赞，我们就完成了。如果我们得到 20 个不同的剧集，人们意见不一，那我们就看看点赞数，然后进行最终投票什么的，就这样。但是，你知道，这太复杂了。
But your method produces unclean data. It's just like a series of textual comments and maybe upvotes on a GitHub discussion. My method's more fun. I'm going to do research on this. I'm going to do research on this. I'm going to ask by research, I mean I'm going to ask chat GPT. I tell you what, you build some kind of voting mechanism. People can also just go leave comments on this GitHub discussion.
但你的方法产生的数据不干净。这只是一系列文本评论，也许是 GitHub 讨论上的点赞。我的方法更有趣。我要对此进行研究。我要对此进行研究。我说的研究是指我要问 ChatGPT。我告诉你，你建立某种投票机制。人们也可以直接在这个 GitHub 讨论中留下评论。
Or maybe I'll set up a separate one. Just link in the show notes for a link to somewhere where you can leave a comment. And then if Bryce actually puts this together before Friday when this episode drops, then I will link to his as well and we will see which is better. All right, anyways, we're almost at the 40 minute mark now. Is there any in the last 30 seconds here, anything else, retro 2025, things we want to mention before we go forward to our 2026 look ahead, predictions, future episode? No, I think, I think this has gone on as long as it should go on.
或者我可能会设置一个单独的讨论。在节目说明中放一个链接，指向你可以留下评论的地方。如果 Bryce 在周五这一集发布之前真的把它做好了，那么我也会链接到他的，我们会看看哪个更好。好了，无论如何，我们现在快到 40 分钟了。在最后 30 秒里，还有什么关于 2025 年回顾的事情，在我们展望 2026 年的预测和未来剧集之前想提到的吗？不，我想，我想这已经进行得够久了。
All right, folks, that's episode. What episode is that? That is episode 269. We are now on to 270. 2025. It's in the rear view, mere. 2026 is here. It is January 13th as we record this.
好了，各位，这就是这一集。这是第几集？这是第 269 集。我们现在进入 270 集。2025 年。它已经在后视镜里了。2026 年到了。我们录制时是 1 月 13 日。
Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP the podcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day.
请务必查看这些节目说明，无论是在您的播客应用程序中还是在 ADSP the podcast.com 上，获取我们在今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，您可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望您喜欢，祝您有美好的一天。
Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast. It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的标语。这不是标语。我们的标语是充满信息碎片的混乱。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。